Northern India is dominated by the  indo-aryan languages including Hindi  Bengali Punjabi and others Southern  India is dominated by an entirely  unrelated language family the dravidian  languages which include Tamil Telugu  kannada Malayalam and others they're  spoken by approximately 20 percent of  Indians Pakistan is more culturally and  linguistically connected to Northern  India and doesn't have the same  north-south distinction there is one  dravidian language spoken in Pakistan  but it's spoken by just over one percent  of the population Pakistan is dominated  by indo-aryan languages in the east and  by Iranian languages in the west part of  the larger indo-iranian branch of the  Indo-European language family